so there's some, uh, pretty bad news for Bernie
Sanders in a recent poll, which says that
Ernie support among young voters has dropped
significantly.
Now, I hate that I have to do this sometimes
multiple times in one show, but as a reminder,
I am just the messenger here.
Okay?
I didn't do this poll.
I'm not anti Bernie.
I like Bernie.
He's one of my top candidates for 2020.
I voted for him in the 2016 primary.
I'm telling you the news, which is what this
poll is asserting, I am not the person that
you should attack simply for telling you that
this is a poll that has been released.
Now these numbers are from a new morning consult
poll.
Bernie has been super strong in the 18 to
29 age bracket and in the same pole, morning
consult back in February, Bernie had support
from 46% of those age 18 to 29 in March, almost
the same.
He still had 45% of 18 to 29 year olds supporting
him.
This number has now dropped to 33% in May.
That's a reduction of more than 25% in the
support from young people.
So the obvious question is who is that 18
to 29 year old cohort, but moving towards
in the 2020 Democratic primary?
And the answer is maybe surprising to some
in our audience because a bunch of that support
has moved over to Joe Biden and I know many
in our audience will say and have been saying,
David, only old people are supporting Joe
Biden.
And it's true that Joe Biden has disproportionate
support from older voters, but according to
this poll, Joe Biden has gone from under 20%
support from 18 to 29 year olds, 29 year olds,
up to 24% in the latest survey.
Elizabeth Warren has also increased her support.
She's gone from around 5% support from 18
to 29 year olds in March up to more like 10%
now.
And that's the majority or a significant portion
rather have the support that Bernie has lost
from that age group.
So let's go through it.
First of all, are there any glaring methodology
issues which would suggest that the poll results
are just completely wrong?
Nothing obvious that I was able to find when
I looked at it.
The next question is, will it matter if there's
been a shift in 18 to 29 year old support
from Bernie to Warren and from Bernie to Biden?
If 18 to 29 year olds don't show up to vote.
And what I mean by that is that historically
older voters are much more reliable voters,
whereas young voters are less likely to vote
once election day actually arrives.
And once we think about that, we have to ask
why is it that some of the 18 to 29 year olds
who were supporting Bernie Sanders a month
ago, two months ago, why have they moved on
to someone else?
And why would it be Biden and why would it
be Elizabeth Warren?
Uh, when it comes to Biden, it's not likely
to be over Biden's politics specifically.
I mean, Biden is very moderate.
He is very much in the line of Hillary Clinton.
Not drastically different from, you know,
a 1970s moderate Republican in many ways,
but I think it's undeniable that Biden's perceived
association with the Obama Presidency around
which people on the older end of 18 to 29
may remember positively and have some nostalgia
for particularly when you look at who's in
the White House right now.
Um, when it comes to some of that Bernie 18
to 29 year olds support shifting to Elizabeth
Warren.
There is a contingent that liked Elizabeth
Warren in 2016 but ended up with Bernie as
sort of the closest person to Warren that
they actually had a chance to vote for, uh,
during the 2016 primary.
They may simply be reinvigorated by the fact
that Elizabeth Warren's campaign is getting
more attention in the last four to six weeks.
It's been picking up some polling steam.
And my message if want Bernie to win, is very
simple.
Don't react to this story by don't, don't
react by attacking me because that will do
nothing to help Bernie Sanders win.
Um, don't react by attacking Joe Biden or
whoever.
Go and volunteer for Bernie's campaign and
make the case to people who are already on
the left that you believe Bernie is their
best, their best option from those that are
available.
Remember that a spirited primary, uh, healthy,
uh, disagreement within the primary, it's
not a bad thing even if Bernie Sanders is
losing support.
Because my guess is that in the end, most
Warren supporters, if Bernie's the nominee
are going to vote for Bernie.
Okay.
Most Bernie supporters, if Warren is the nominee,
are going to vote for Elizabeth Warren.
Whether they all would vote for Joe Biden
if Biden's the nominee.
I'm a little bit more concerned about, but
the point is, it's okay for the progressive
contingent to be sort of divided.
At this point in time we've seen as I predicted
would happen as soon as Joe Biden announced
his candidacy, the establishment support has
coalesced around him.
So Beto has been dropping.
Cory Booker has been dropping and that establishment
centrist wing has been seriously just joining
Joe Biden effectively.
And that's why his poll numbers are doing
well.
The progressive vote is still very much more
split between candidates and it doesn't really
necessarily tell us what it is that's going
to happen once the Democratic primary is settled.
I think most of those voters who now are split
are going to come over to the democratic,
uh, a nominee almost, no matter who it is.
I will put it that way and maybe we'll dig
into what I mean by that.
Uh, on an upcoming show,